euh pour le moment ce matin le premier
Conseil des ministres de l'air à Gabriel
Attal a euu à l'isée 14 ministres
étaient autour du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron et du Premier
ministre Gabriel Attal 14 ministres pour
k laavi n'est plus la même lorsqu'ils
sont nommés argent chauffeur logement de
fonction les avantages sont nombreux
dans un instant on va tout vous dire sur
les salaires qui gagne combien sur les
avantages qui a le droit euh à part
Patrick Bruel
euh qui a le droit à quoi il y a
Frédéric mtiran qu'on adore on sa un
ministre de la Culture ancien grand
présentateur de télévision d' il était
excellent euh Frédéric mitteran très
très fort était sur T et tout c'était
c'est une star et ministre de la Culture
très bon ministre de la Culture ça nous
a changé de Rima abdoumak qui nous
expliquera comment ça se passe lorsqu'on
apprend qu'on va être ministre et tout
ce qui change dans la vie et puis yenad
qui a bossé pour bah chouchout Marlen
Chiapa voilà il nous manque au
gouvernement nous manquera beaucoup
moins que Rima Abdou Malak euh qui qui
sera également avec nous et qui nous
dira comment ça se passe surtout comment
quand on est viré comme Rima
Abd regardez petit sans Rima abdoum
[Musique]
cette semaine Gabriel Atal est devenu à
seulement 34 ans le plus jeune premier
ministre de l'histoire de la 5e
République qu'il n'y a rien de plus beau
rien de plus fort rien de plus grand que
de servir la France et les Français et
parmi les membres qui composent le
nouveau gouvernement Stéphane séjourné
nommé ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères je remercie le
président de la République et et le
Premier ministre pour pour leur
confiance mais cette nomination est
aujourd'hui vue d'un mauvais œil par
certains car n'est autre que l'ancien
compagnon de Gabriel Atal avec qui il a
même été paxé autre sujet qui fait
grandement parler avec ce remaniment les
avantages auquels les ministres sortant
et entrant peuvent prétendre alors quels
sont-ils Gabriel Atal salaire avantage
richesse tout savoir sur les ministres
ce soir dans
TPMP 20h46 on est en direct merci
Frédéric Méran ancien ministre de la
Culture 2009-202 bonne année bah merci
bonne année à vous également Frédéric
merci et yen d'ancien conseiller de
Marline chappa et qui vient nous voir
plus souvent il faut que tu viennes nous
voir plus souvent dans l'émission parce
que tu es excellent alors déjà sur la
nomination de l'ancien compagnon de
Gabriel hatal je vais vous dire al ça
c'est une fausse polémique je vais la
dire tout de suite il est excellent je
vous le dis c'est un c'est un garçon qui
a fait qui qui qui qui a j'ai eu la
chance de le connaître et je peux vous
dire que partout où il passe tout le
monde dit qu'il est exceptionnel donc je
vais vous dire quand on a il est
exceptionnel c'est un mec qui est c'est
une tête c'est une tronche incroyable
donc je vais vous dire si dans notre
entourage on a des mecs qu'on trouve
extrêmement talentueux bah oui on va
travailler avec eux euh moi quand j'ai
pris touche pas mon poste j'ai appelé
Valéri Benaim voilà euh non non mais non
mais non mais
franchement bien sû non mais je vais
vous dire çaè fois que je viens aussi
hein bah oui c'est un faux débat total
j'ai même pas envie de débattre
là-dessus parce que je vous le dis il
est exceptionnel c'est hors sujet et
alors je vais vous dire ça c'est les
mecs qui qui qui les les les jaloux qui
veulent trouver la petite bête et qui
qui vont s'arrêter à à telle ou telle
chose je peux vous dire il est excellent
je vous le dis c'est il est très fort
moi si demain je cherche quelqu'un pour
mon entreprise c'est un des premiers que
j'aurais appelé donc voilà c'est un mec
qui est partout où il va je vous dis il
est en réussite il y a des mecs qui
réussissent partout hein voilà mettez
n'importe où ils réussiront bah vous
allez voir qu'il va être un excellent
ministre merci en tout cas parce que
comme ça là la parenthèse est fermée
parce que j'en ai marre des jalou pe
petite parenthèse je pense que si ça
avait été un couplé terro
potentiellement il y aurait quand même
moins de de de poléque Roy pas c'est
c'est
vraimentent polé sex pour une catégorie
de personnees qui
est de se jeter dessus enlevez-moi
d'ailleurs enlevez-moi d'ailleurs ça là
enlevez-moi ça je supporte pas c'est
c'est n'importe quoi ça c'est des
abrutis qui ont qui ont soulevé le le
débat et nous on le relaye derrière donc
on le relaye même pas on close le débat
direct merci en tout cas à vous deux
d'être là alors Rachid adati ministre de
la culture c'est un bon choix non oui
c'est un bon choixi je trve c'est une
idée surprenante tout le monde a été
surpris évidemment elle elle-même
peut-être aussi d'ailleurs mais c'est un
bon choix parce que c'est un ministère
qui a besoin
d'être d'être non pas dynamisé parce que
on a la ministre avant était excellente
r Abd oui excellente non non non mais je
sais que je sais qu'il faut pas parler
de cor dans la maison d'endu en tout cas
elle était
excellente non mais je dire céit une
connerie à la
minute corde dans la maison d'un pendu
je commence par une gaffe
mais commence toujours par une gaffe
toute façon très bien quand j'étais
nommé ministre je l'ai dit tout de suite
à un journaliste qui immédiatement l'
l'a dit à tout le monde alors qu'il
fallait pas le dire donc je commence
souvent par une gaffe mais après je me
rattrape assez bien non non ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'elle avait
très très bien préparé les dossiers don
ah bah les dossiers c'est les faire ou
les photocopies tout ça ok d'accord
j'arrête pas on va pas commencer
là-dessus non mais si elle était bonne
dans les photocopies tout ça je le sais
non mais Frédéric comment vous avez qui
vous l' annoncz vous que vous alleiez
être ministre quand vous avez été nommé
ministre qui vous l' annoncé c'est
Nicolas Sarkozy qui me l'annon
directement ouais ouais comment comment
vous avez réagi vous attendez pas j'ai
dit oui tout de suite mais je me doutais
de quelque chose ah ouais parce que
j'étais à la ville la Médicis et depuis
depuis 6 mois il y avait de plus en plus
de gens importants qui venaient visiter
la ville là Christine Lagarde François
Fillon et C dis mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils viennent c'est pas ils ont autre
chose à faire quand même que d'aller
respirer le Bonner de Rome à la ville la
méicis ou prendre un thé avec Frédéric
miteron je me disais que d'une certaine
manière on tester en fait et comme je me
me débrouillais pas trop mal à la ville
là mais finalement hop c'est venu comme
ça vous débrouillez bien partout pardon
vous débrouillez bien partout non non
regardez comment j'ai commencé là
Ren pas toujours par une gaffe non pas
du tout c'est c'est quoi quand on arrive
parce que c'est on se dit on est
ministre on a jamais fait ça quand vous
arrivez comment ça se passe il y a quoi
il y a quelqu'un qui vous guide qui vous
dit voilà c il y a une chose il une
chose c'est que dans ma famille j'ai eu
quelqu'un qui a fait la politique ah
c'était un copain de ma mère voilà et
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a fait de la
politique donc je suis assez j'ai pas
été surpris du tout par le
fonctionnement parce que pas
impressionné quoi non mon père était
très très proche de François ouais donc
j'ai passé toute mon enfance quand
François avait des difficultés on en
parlait tout le temps à la maison et on
était solidaire et quand il a moindre
difficulté qui est du président de la
République qu'on était aussi solidaire à
ce moment-là moi j'allais plus le voir
d'ailleurs parce que j'avais ça ça me
faisait peur un peu je voulais pas être
pris dans le système mais quand même
j'avais l'habitude je savais comment ça
marche bon non mais quand c'est arrivé
moi de toute façon je sais pas je cyile
j'ai pas peur ouais je sais pas pourquoi
je suis pas quelqu'un de
particulièrement courageux mais j'ai pas
peur donc voilà non vous aviez fait de
la télé avant vous avez tu arrivé comme
ça je suis arrivé avec mon scooter j'ai
un monsieur qui m'a dit je suis le
commandant machin je serai vre votre
officier de sécurité bon ben très bien
puis je suis allé dans mon bureau et
puis voilà c'est vous la Seu chose qui
m'embêtait la seule chose qui m'embêtait
la seule chose qui m'embêta c'est que je
succédais à quelqu'un pour qui j'avais
beaucoup d'estime qui était Madame
Albanel ah ouais qui était une femme
très bien très sympa ouais une femme
très bien était bien ouais et puis une
grande une grande littéraire c'est elle
qui avait fait c'est elle qui avait
notamment contribuer au meilleur
discours de Chirac le discours que
Chirac a fait quand François miteran est
mort un discours absolument form sur le
thème on était ennemis on était
adversaire et cetera mais je le
respectais elle avait fait c elle qui
avait fait le texte cétait absolument
magnifique donc j'avais beaucoup de
respect pour cette femme et j'étais
j'étais embêté de lui succéder comme ça
brutalement mais bon surtout que j'avais
pas du tout intrigué pour devenir
ministre j'avais rien fait je et voilà
bon alors ça c'était la seule chose le
seul bémol quand on est ministre y vous
êtes ancien conseiller de Marline Chapa
nous ce qu'on aimerait savoir c'est
c'est combien gagne un ministre un
ministre c'est
pr c'est quoi les avantages pour un
ministre alors un ministre a un
chauffeur ouis oui il a des billets
d'avion et de trains qui sont aussi pour
travailler pas pour partir en vacan
c'est pas pour pas commeidalgo c'est pas
pour partir à non non non c'est des
billets pour se déplacer
qui elle a payé son billet de retour ou
ouais B oui moi aussi j'ai payé mon
billet de
retour s fait grill mais je voulais pas
aller là non
plus
c'est c'est terrible cette émission je
vais faire fa les
gaffeessay de pas en faire trop j'adore
et Frédérique moi j'adore au contraire
ça me chauffeade donc il y a quoi
d'autre on a un logement de fonction
aussi moi j'avais pas de logement de
fonction certains peuvent avoir un
logement de fonction moi pas besoin il y
a certains ministres qui sont obligés
d'être sur place dans le ministère je
pense au ministre de l'Intérieur pour
des questions de sécurité il est obligé
d'être sur place ah ouais c'est dire Gal
Harin il d tout à fait oui parce qu'on
l'appelle à 2h du matin il faut qu'il
soit il descend dans son pyjama Micke et
il
il prend l'ascenseur il descend 5 étages
et et
voilà non mais c'est vrai c'est comme ça
oui ouais donc oui mais on a donc on a
un bon salaire mais il faut vous dire
aussi une chose qui est très très
étrange c'est quand même tout d'un coup
on se retrouve à la tête d'une énorme
entreprise ouais c'est ça le ministère
de la Culture c'était de mon temps
c'était au moins 30000 personnes hein
oui 300 personnes ou oui vous avez les
gardiens des musé vous avez les gens qui
travaillent dans les théâtres vous avezz
300 personnes et 300 personnes pas pas
qui font rien travaille vraiment alors
ça fait quand même un énorme un énorme
truc et vous êtes en quelque sorte le
patron de ces gensl avec syndicat aussi
évidemment qui vous le font sentir à
leur manière donc tout ça est assez
compliqué ça j'avais pas l'habitude
c'est S mais je dis comme je vous dis
tout à l'heure pas peur donc vous avez
peur
vous peur bon B très
bien peur quand je me suis retrouvé
quand je me suis
retrouvé au journal Le 20h quand il y a
eu toute l'histoire avec Marine Le Pen
mon livre et cetera et que je devais
m'expliquer quand même au journal de 20h
en direct j'avais ma mère au téléphone
qui était en larme avant en me disant ça
recommence c'est comme l'affaire de
l'Observatoire avec François et cetera
c'est terrible mon fils qu'est-ce que tu
as fait et
cetera rien n'avez pas eu peur pas du
tout non parce que je j'ai peur quand je
suis en
bah voilà mais quand je suis pas en tort
je je savais tout le monde considérait
que j'étais en tort moi je savais que
j'étais pas en tort donc j'avais pas
peur donc je me suis assez bien défendu
d'ailleurs yenad alors quand on est
ministre on est le roi du monde mais
comment ça se passe quand on n'est plus
ministre comment ça se passe ben c'est
ce que disait rfarin on monte dans la
voiture et puis elle démarre plus c'est
ça non mais c'est vrai derrière elle
démar c'est vrai non c'est mais du jour
au lendemain on est on passe du centre
de l'attention à à plus rien d'une
seconde à l'autre d'une seconde à
l'autre il faut il faut même partir
assez vite c'est fini genre il faut
partir vite du jour au lendemain il faut
faire ses cartons et on vous dit il faut
partir assez vite j'ai une anecdote
assez marrante d'ailleurs là-dessus
c'est que quand il y a un ministre qui
change dans un ministère généralement
les équipes changent donc les équipes
doivent partir ou il y a un directeur de
cabinet il y a quelques années qui a
décidé de rester entre les murs et de ne
pas partir et quand le nouveau ministre
est arrivé il s'est présenté en lui
disant monsieur le ministre je suis
votre nouveau directeur de cabinet et il
est resté ah ou mais est
fait je pense que je vais faire pareil
après l'émission je vais rester dans le
local technique comme ça encore
là une confidence qui pas très amusante
j'avais une de mes tantes que j'adorais
une des sœurs de François miléran mais
qui était très fantasque elle avait eu
des des revers de fortune et cetera et
donc François myteran malade et ca
l'avait installé dans son appartement à
l'Élysée fin de François mitteran donc
lui explique écoute maintenant il faut
que tu trouves un autrre endroit parce
que c'est terminé ah non non pas du tout
j'ai parlé avec Madame Chirac alors je
peux
rester c'est génial non elle était
complètement incciente et très
sympathique vous étiez triste quand vous
étiez triste quand vous avez dû quitter
votre poste vous étiez triste non non
c'est ça prend du
temps sur le moment on est on est encore
sur la
lancée ce qui est en en ce qui est de
plus en plus en milieu c'est quand on se
rend compte que des choses bien parce
qu'on on on sait quand on fait des
choses mal mais quand on fait des choses
bien quand on a fait des choses bien et
qu'on voit qu'elles sont abandonnées
ouis alors ça ça rend très triste et ça
ça vient peu à peu c'est une sensation
qui vient peu à peu pas pas tout de
suite y elle était triste Marline ou pas
quand elle était pas triste la politique
c'est pas un métier Marline par exemple
elle a eu une vie avant elle a une vie
après maintenant je pense que c'est
important de se dire que la politique
c'est un début ça a aussi une fin ah
mais c'est c'est Durou c'est dur mais
c'est important de pas en faire un
métier de pas dédier toute sa vie ça
permet déjà d'être plus connecté avec
les gens et d'avoir d'être plus réaliste
dans sa pratique de la politique mais
oui Mo personnellement j'ai vu quefin
j'aiti que la politique était pas un
métier tu es jeune mais tu es très tu es
jeune et tu es très sage quand on est
plus âgé on est moins sage exactement
regardez Daniel Mor en vérité on est
moins sage et en fait en fait ça
manque manque terriblement c'est comme
c'est comme les gens qui ont fait des
des films importants ou qui ont joué
dans des pièces de théâre Ant télé même
ça manque c'est pas tellement le la télé
c'est pas tellement le pouvoir qui
manque je vous dis précisément sur ce
que je je viens de dire c'est c'est pas
le pouvoir qui manque c'est le fait que
ah ça je pourrais faire ça et puis on
peut pas ou ça je pourrait lui dire et
on peut pas et alors qu'avant on pouvait
et ça c'est une chose qui est qui est
très très pas douloureuse mais qui est
très pénible quand même et qui ne
s'efface pas 10 ans plus tard j'en suis
encore là à me dire voilà c'est pour ça
que je trouve que le le le choix de
Rached hadti est un très bon choix
excellent parce que elle va euh elle va
avoir une relation très très saine à la
politique elle va avoir une relation
sans doute
brutale mais bon de toute façon la
politique est incroyablement brutale et
elle va se faire respecter et je pense
qu'elle va se faire respecter par ceuxl
même qui l'ont nommé c'est-à-dire que je
pense qu'il il ne soupçonne pas à quel
point elle va être elle va être
alors c'est surtout un coup politique de
la part du président de la République
parce que en la nommant ministre il
s'assure en tout cas il il a manœuvré
pour que ce soit la prochaine maire de
Paris c'està-dire qu'au prochaines
élections le parti présidentiel ne va
pas mettre de candidat face à elle et
lui permettre peut-être la prochaine
maère de Paris et de battre
an dev faire vra
beauoupalgo qui trouvera certainement un
poste chez tahi douche merci fa pas cere
de calcul stratégie je pense jamais à ça
ouais mais il a raison il a raison
j'espère j'espère qu'elle va gagner les
prochaines élections à Paris Rachid
adati même si ça va pas plaire à Gilles
Verdez le rat de Paris euh merci merci
Frédéric mééant merci yenat d'avoir été
avec nous yen il faudra venir nous voir
semaine prochaine Frédéric t plaisir de
vous bientôt même si vous parlez de gens
que j'aime pas j'adore c'est je vais
faire une liste pour la prochaine fois
long merci Frédéric en tout cas avec
plaisir euh